[Music]
foreign
hey guys so if you're not watching this
on youtube
frankly i pity you because if you were
watching you would see me
getting my hair done while we are
recording this podcast open
it's been it's been um
it's just been a smash and grab these
last couple weeks the world's opened up
we're on tour
we're doing 10 cities of city time in
the city
i am so delirious and tired this open's
gonna be a wild one
i went on i went to san antonio i went
to raleigh north carolina i went to
was the other city we went to spokane
washington
and um i have had such a
like i'm so uh it's so good to be back
and
it's not i'm not just saying that
because i'm high off the bleach that is
currently on my scalp
and uh that i am inhaling just uh to
keep hope
emily what are you doing emily's putting
on my robot's wig transformation
is completely horse horse is that your
impression to me
horses horses but who is that too
the fan the fan
emily's favorite new joke is let's shoot
this for our fan
we have many fans this braid many
okay emily i braided a part of this wig
that was on my robot
because i'm a topanga lady and
i wanted a khaleesi topanga lady vibe
yeah
you know that that's not the lace front
it's not even on brad
you're not even you like this okay no i
mean there's no no you have no forehead
now
you had too much forehead before to be
fair
[Music]
i look offended but you can't tell
because there's so much botox in my
forehead
emily went on a little rum springer with
the old botox
and she this is my eyebrows all the way
up
[Laughter]
she you do kind of look like a troll
doll right now
remember those troll dolls okay i need
to stop giving you
future the future ability to sue me so
let's get back to
uh the touring san antonio y'all were
so fun and grace and i were there and so
much funny shit happened we're gonna
play
uh the videos on the youtube and clips
and stuff
i made out with lesbians not one lesbian
but
two lesbians were they a couple are you
friends they were a couple
they were a couple not anymore probably
i think i broke them up one was
russian and i got so obsessed because
you know i'm obsessed with russian
people in russia
you didn't know that i had no idea
i'm obsessed with russia every time i
talk to a russian person
like movers or anyone that i can meet
spaceba online of my russianbride.net
i ask them is it true
that uh what's his name putin vladimir
vlad vlad
that vladimir putin that he has a double
that was given all this plastic surgery
so that
he the plastic surgery vladimir putin
would do appearances and he won't go out
well that's what you say about melania
did oh she had a double yeah no she just
said my plastic surgeon
but here's me uh let me see kissing
these lesbians
because they gave me some hot intel on
vladimir putin
all right let's see
[Applause]
oh i let her feel my face oh okay she'd
never felt fake tits before for some
reason i feel the need i'm just so
excited to be touched that's an
interesting
footnote um i can't believe you didn't
lead with
[Applause]
i that to make some calls
they were so fun and she went right for
the kisser and look at this
in uh in uh this was in spokane
i made out with as many older men as i
could because now i'm dating a
younger lad smart retirement player i
miss that like
like um skin that smells like it was
shaved with no shaving cream
i miss like a like an old guy who has
like a little bandage where he cut
himself shaving it's a little tiny piece
of toilet paper
paper i love an older man it's like
daddy daddy
daddy daddy do you smell like gold spice
okay so i kissed this man
now it was his wife there or his partner
his wife was there and all the wives
were very encouraging of it they were
like
yeah they're like now i don't have to
give him a thrill because i'm i
i quit so this was my other guy
oh that's his wife so cute she was so
excited i like kissing an older man wait
how does this happen like how do we get
to the kisses buy tickets to the show
and you never know what the hell is
going to happen because i
am off the rails even more off the rails
than i have been during quarantine i
have to
kick it up a notch and start using
tongue and i'm so oh you just wait
uh i want to i'm just so desperate to
like it's been so good to just like be
around people and see people and be able
to like
touch people i mean i'm calling the tour
touch me it's perfect it's gonna be the
fall tour this is a woman that i got to
make out with uh
first night uh she was sitting in the
corner and she just had
such pillowy looking lips and i just she
drove five hours to see me
um in spokane from i don't know some
like portland or something so gave her
a smacker caitlyn here
i'm very into it yeah
we did have a moment we did have a
moment where my lover was there
and was watching my stories and was like
so if i just kiss
girls at work would that be like is this
cheating
is kissing someone else on stage
like as a fun joke after the show
surprise
no cheating no and there's no tongue uh
there was no tongue but there was some
other inappropriate shit that went down
and then oh god san antonio was so funny
first of all
grace and i were uh walking around san
antonio which i strongly believe is kind
of the new austin
austin got a little corporate i mean
because everyone's moving there we
literally got there got in the car with
uh this you know texas
like longhorn was that a long
yeah longhorn sorry well i mean not he
was whatever oh he wasn't a steer
you guys it wasn't a bowl thank you for
clearing that it was a human
window and so
uh get in the car and he's like oh y'all
live in l.a and oh he started putting
together
you know who i was and he goes can you
please tell your friends to stop fucking
moving here
i mean they are pissed the locals are
pissed about this whole influx
from california and i was also just
abroad i was just in raleigh
uh north carolina they're getting a ton
of them too and i was talking about
people
and i was like this place is beautiful
like i love this neighborhood they're
like do not move here don't tell anyone
please
literally um and yeah we were we kind of
had our hearts broken when we saw a nike
town on south congress
and was that in san antonio and um nope
in austin like the main strip i was like
let's go to these thrift stores i need
more horse shirts
let's get some wool shirts from the you
know 70s right and all of the antique
malls and thrift stores it might have
been kazakovic but
i don't know anyway moving on to
something hilarious
so i'm driving i'm wearing the wildest
outfit for whatever reason
when we're walking around san antonio uh
i'm wearing like neon
i'll just show them to you right now so
it's like these neon
shorts like bike shorts and whatever
walk around san antonio and i'm
hip and this guy drives by
in a black uh vw bug with flames on the
side
okay drives by and he goes love that
color combination
like a very sweet and i just because
that's the only thing i would have
needed to hear yeah
not nice ass or i was just like and so i
was like i agree
right i don't like that he encourages
this no stop it
grow up i'm big on cat calling can i
tell you no i'm saying that he
encourages
your outfit choices oh got it yeah yeah
well cat calling out you're gonna have
to be like you
whore i'd rather be like get your butt
ass in this
i don't know oh my god emily emily is
incapable of being evil and it is
so cute um and so he goes love that
color combination and i went i agree
and then he went a little bit forward
and he went i'm serious
and i went all so am i i didn't think
you weren't
as he was driving away it's a compliment
and i went
i agree i know texans are nice
so then he comes back around we're
walking being like that was such a
constructive cat call yeah that was so
helpful i actually that's the only thing
i wouldn't need to hear and i'm really
into these neon weird
mixes these days he comes back around
and he goes uh
in front of me makes the block and goes
yells out the window
are you always this cocky oh my god
and then i was like dude that was a 180.
i know it's like dude i
i think you're projecting something onto
me maybe look at that
because i'm i'm on your team you said
all of this while he was driving yeah
no dude maybe like check your attachment
strategy or like i don't know listen to
the podcast
for you listen to the podcast maybe get
into your ancestral trauma because i'm
on your side
it's like men are so afraid to cat call
now and even when they do it positively
he had some kind of shame had to ruin it
it was
in his shame but no it was like his
insecurity i'm like
i'm fine he's the one that went into a
spiral
men are now the victim of the cat
calling because they feel so bad
so as he went around the block he was
having some kind of shame spiral
and then came back and then was like i
tried to do something nice and she
didn't receive it the way i wanted her
to receive it and it's like but you did
receive that i know but then it turned
to anger we don't
work why are you trying to rationalize i
always rationalize crazy people
i work for you i have to okay well
well i believe you mean high functioning
eccentric
fairy and visionary oh dear so then
emily you'll love this we went into a
store okay and there was an adorable
kid uh i just kind of wanted to get like
some tchotchkes and stuff for the uh
for that just for the is that what can
we not say that no i loved it is that
like against russian short people or
something
um am i not allowed to call a russian
little person
a russian nesting doll okay
only if they're inside another bigger
one only
wait can i call a russian pregnant
woman's baby in her belly a russian
nesting doll
okay got it okay so we went into the
store and
this little kid because i can only i can
only really talk to kids
and animals mm-hmm and understand them
so
he brought me all around this good job
so i said buy i will buy anything in
here that has a horse on it did he work
there
well yeah i mean he was like uh whatever
the kid in the store okay
you know stores come with a kid sell to
other customers because once a customer
is giving you their money you got to
just move on to the next day
there's food right there you know what
and then he tried to make
everything look like a horse what a
salesman it was genius so like the llama
he's like that's a horse like the dog
he's like
that sort of like i think it's a dog he
was like not all horses look the same
like he was like kind of a genius trying
to get me to buy
stuff that is a good thing if you're if
you work at a store and you need people
to be emotionally manipulated
um uh put a kid in it oh my god
i made a big boo boo let me hear it i
because
you you called it about how we're all
gonna have to like relearn social
behaviors
we're all a little rusty when i went on
my first
flight to uh first light like in a year
right in a couple months or whatever
like city i
was i was just like so excited to talk
to anyone or like have any kind of
social
interaction with people that i um i was
like will ferrell from elf
i'd be like hello i saw a dog today
like i was that's the world's best
coffee you did it like i was so
like a child yeah at disneyland just
seeing humans i hear that
and uh and so um uh this story is like
it is very embarrassing we might need to
do tell it okay so
i'm on a plane and i see a team like a
basketball you know when you see like a
college team
like um all walking in with the same
jerseys and it's like obviously a female
team
they're in their jerseys and i'm
thinking oh like this is like a college
basketball team but then i saw that they
were all white so i was like volleyball
and then i'm sitting in there and i'm
like how can i what can i do for them
which is so codependent i know but
i think just after the pandemic i was so
desperate to like help bring people
together in some way or like
like and also i have all these weirdly i
know a lot of really famous people
for i don't even know why and i like to
connect them with the people that they
uh inspired so i'm like oh my god i know
gabby reese gabriel reese she was
an olympian volleyball player in the 90s
sports illustrated
model married laird hamilton told
gangster and i'm like
these girls definitely idolize her like
know her they exist because of what she
did right
so i go up to them and baggage claim and
i'm like hey guys
i know gabby rhys and they're like like
okay let's make her a video this will
totally make her day you can tell her
how
you know whatever she's done for you and
everyone's gonna like feel feel good
moments right and so uh gabby is on a
plane so i make a video
and i've been hanging out with comedians
and doing a podcast where i can kind of
say whatever the fuck i want yeah
for the past year so i'm just like
what's up cunts look at these bitches
and i'm like we got to give them some
advice so they can take over the world
but it's a video so i'm just like make
sure to do your kegels girls
right gabby get some plan b's put them
in your back pocket you know
and i'm going on and on with just the
most like do not bleach your asshole
even if your man wants you to i'm going
on and on put it down
text it to gabby like 20 minutes later i
get a text from gabby that says did you
not see that they were wearing jerseys
that said brigham young university
that is in edible and i'm so
mad i wasn't there it was pretty bright
they probably all got expelled
for being in that video i'm going to
what about me i'm not right with god
oh no that is i didn't post it i didn't
post it
oh maybe i got that have i ever taken a
film something i didn't think it was the
best
it's a story oh my god and then okay
last story i know we have to get to
jamie lee is here host
of the wedding coach on netflix she's
hilarious
i'm wearing a wedding dress we're going
to go through all my wedding dress pics
for when i emily and i uh marry each
other marry each other for tag purposes
yep and i'm not signing a prenup so
we're
so we're at um in idaho
i do not have my driver's license right
now and i and i had not traveled and
i like i'm not i'm still rusty on
traveling and all the logistics and the
like
you know like the octopus like you have
to have nine things in your hands at all
times
yes i love my license and you can get
through tsa
without a license but you have to have
another form of id
and like a couple credit cards so then
you have to go the regular tsa security
thing you can't go through tuesday i do
not know that whatever yeah oh i know a
lot about tsa all of a sudden
and so i go in and normally they'll like
know they'll be like oh it's waiting
like
let's just let her like let's not she's
a live one let's start with her she's
gonna
end up on her instagram yeah we don't
want to deal with whitney end up on her
instagram
um and so in idaho we had my twin
look her up if you are listening april
tillman we're gonna have a picture up
um in the show and uh this girl looks
exactly like me i met her in portland
one day i was doing a show
at helium in portland and i went to take
a drink of water during the show just to
take a little
little break because sometimes you get
carp like lockjaw before you drive
yeah and so um and uh
this girl went our friend looks exactly
like you and i was like
here we go this is about to hurt my
feelings and then i'm like you know what
fuck it come on
come on up here sometimes let me see
what you got yeah sometimes you've been
doing the same material so you just want
to freshen up a show and give an
interactive fun
um she comes up
i literally screamed at the top of my
lungs the entire audience was like
oh like she looks exactly like me it's
spooky
it's so it we have the same like teeth
and mouth like everything and you guys
will see there's a lot of content coming
soon but the point
is i do not have my license i'm leaving
spokane washington
she leaves at 8 a.m and then i'm leaving
at like 10 a.m or something
a tiny tiny airport so i go through the
airport and i'm like hey guys i don't
have my license but i know the whole
rigmarole i have two
two copies of my license and password
went to credit cards and i just need to
go through some extra security and
they're like they look at me
real weird and i'm like no no i i i
totally
i mean i've had to do this i hear my
tickets from the last couple of ones
just to see other
tsas have let me through and uh and
they're like no you i know
you're whitney cummings right oh and i
was like yeah yeah yeah and they're like
well she just came through here and so
we're trying and i was like
so suddenly i became a crazy person
pretending to be whitney cummings i have
like blue hair you've come full circle
that is not brushed
right i have you've seen the lug my
luggage is like clear plastic bags
from trash bags etsy basically and then
i'm carrying all this crazy shit my hair
is blue and then of course i say the
thing that is like my nightmare makes me
hate myself being on comprehension i was
like well if you want to just
google me and see how my hair is blue
now and they were just like
it was i just was once once you
think whitney already came through me
everything i said
in the frame of that reality sounded
fucking insane and then remember i
started i literally started crying
afterwards
i was so embarrassed i was so
embarrassed and then
i i was trying to talk to them it was
masked and then there were two pieces of
glass between me and the guy in the mask
so like
we couldn't hear each other yeah and
every time i tried to talk to him closer
i would hit my head on the
plexiglass like i looked like a crazy
person we didn't film any of this
it was not good okay oh let's make some
announcements oh i also did the live
sakoshi show
liza koshy who was um a guest the big
youtube the queen of youtube
liza koshy who her tv show lies on
demand the pilot on youtube
i got something like 68 million views
what
and yeah so it's no it's huge it's like
three game of thrones
um that's crazy but anyway she asked me
to be on and i love her and so
i did and i have to just tell you the
craziest thing just
real quick and i don't even know what to
make of this but
my first studio movie i ever did was
called maid of honor
busy phillips michelle monahan was in it
patrick dempsey whatever whatever
always a bridesmaid always a bridesmaid
always um
and i was like you know i was doing it i
was doing the show just mostly for liza
you know she's a friend of mine i kind
of want to see what's going on you know
in terms of shooting youtube shows sort
of how how the the production works et
cetera
so then i'm looking at the script trying
to memorize my lines and i see that it
is written by
uh deb kaplan okay deb kaplan is a huge
writer
in uh hollywood can't hardly wait
yes she wrote can't hardly wait pussycat
dolls like i mean some of the most
yes josie and the pussycats and she has
a writing partner harry elfont who was
just freaking
lovely he was so nice but if you started
in this business wanting to be like an
actress or an actor in any way shape or
form
deb kaplan and harry elephant were on
every script you'd get the breakdowns
and you see
and you you knew that that movie was
gonna happen right because there's a lot
of movies that cast and never go
anywhere
and you're like you know putting your
money on the wrong horse hate horse
racing cancel it
um but so deb kaplan like
she just has this she's like a celebrity
to me you know because i grew up being
like i want to be like deb kaplan and i
wouldn't
and i was in a movie that was written by
deb kaplan uh this one maid of honor
it had someone else did like a pass on
it later so deb kaplan
i work with 15 years ago on a movie
called maid of honor i look
like this okay you look like zoey
deschanel
thanks and then
hold on it bangs 15 years later
and i look
like this
how weird is that okay so
me 15 years ago and her was probably 13
whatever in her movie
13 years later she didn't know she
didn't know there's no way like she
didn't know she wasn't the hair person
she wasn't you know
i am basically the same character 13
years later and i've turned into like a
topanga lady that um
makes her own soap what an accurate
representation of time
isn't that weird yeah i mean that's so
funny it was so
weird like i don't even know what to
make of this coincidence but it was just
such a wild one
because i never really have bangs and i
never have long long long hair the two
times i have
it's the same look and the dress the
same dress
it was so weird we were both like this
is so great that's so
it was very odd yeah this was deb's plan
for you the whole time
ah or my plan for her to be like
remember that character you wrote 13
years ago
i've been here this whole i got lost in
your character i'm a methodology i'm
still here
um okay so i am oh
we have to do some announcements all
right i love you guys i do not want to
blow you
up on instagram twitter i we are sending
community texts so please keep texting
me 818 23975
we are getting back to the daily
birthday messages i promise
because now grace is going to handle it
and so it'll happen because i do try to
do it but i usually
don't remember to do it until like six
at night and then they say this is quiet
time and i don't want to
i don't want to like annoy everybody
with uh
right you know if they keep their phone
on at night and then i'm like hey happy
birthday and they're like what the fuck
it's someone's birthday every day yeah
it could have been for anyone yeah um
okay so please text those and then that
way we can send you
targeted messages in terms of show
updates shows are being added capacities
are being added like some shows that are
now sold out they might add capacity
and have uh more seats available so we
want to be able to just text you
directly and i always like to send it to
the
the true the real ones first so that you
guys can get dibs on tickets first
rhea all shows are sold out except
sunday the 9th may 9th
um texas shows we are coming to dallas
addison improv houston improv
and we are going to do some shows in
austin in between at a place called the
sunset
comedy club sunset strip comedy club it
is
and the creek and the cave let's go
strip in a creek or a cave uh so those
are gonna be announced sometime
soon but uh i'm gonna be doing them i'm
gonna go out and do rogan's show
and then we'll just be there for a
couple days i'm gonna go see the bats
in houston austin okay i have to stop
talking uh
and also my scalp is gonna start burning
out and i don't want y'all to have to
see me go through that what was this
the movie where the girl's hair was
coming out in the shower
the craft oh yeah full craft situation
i love you guys enjoy jamie lee we talk
about weddings
how to have them if you even should have
them uh
nightmares to avoid i'm gonna go through
some wedding dress ideas i'm gonna
i i really go up against a lot of
nuptial
traditions that i think should change um
and i'm pretty
uh outspoken per usual
i love you guys enjoy enjoy enjoy bye
yes i'm available to do the music at
your wedding
hit me up on community we have jamie lee
on the podcast today
uh the great jamie lee who is the host
of a one
the wedding coach on netflix where she
coaches people
through the trials and tribulations of
their wedding days
i thought that i would just show up
in a wedding gown so if you're not
watching this on youtube
you're lost i mean really the boob
adjustment that's happening i am in
i know i just tried to the promise when
i put my boobs too close together it
looks like a little tiny butt
and then i work that's what you want
that's what cleavage is okay then you're
gonna attract pedophiles
because you have a body a little tiny
butt on my chest yeah no that's
wait wait i'm sorry what was that he's
like i get to have a threesome with a
woman and
pedophiles like butts don't they like
tiny butts no they like
kids who have tiny butts okay
okay you're not gonna be the pedophile
coach that's for sure let's stick to
what you're gonna
let's stick to what you're good at i was
opening up
my next career move is not happening
but i thought i would just come in a
full wedding dress uh
that we bought um in salt lake city
uh because this is probably the closest
thing to a wedding day i will ever have
let's be honest
well congratulations this is huge for
you um
so how did this come about
yes yes um well why did they go who
should do this jamie lee the obvious
yeah i i think what happened i know what
happened
is when i got engaged um i wrote a book
about planning my wedding and how
difficult it was
quite stressful yes i remember that
what's it called it's called ridiculous
yes
and yeah and i basically was writing it
as i was getting married so it almost
became
like a diary that then was like a
suicide note
i mean not a tar cry not a far cry
it definitely i had my editor read it
and she's like this is
this is angry are you okay yeah yeah she
was like this is you're really going
through something and i'm like that's
the book
i just i feel like and let's i want to
get really
granular about i love that the wedding
stresses because
you know all my friends are married now
and i just see them in these amazing
relationships they finally find the guy
that's not toxic that's not a narcissist
that doesn't cheat on them that doesn't
wear axe body spray that doesn't
whatever
and then the planning of the wedding
ruins their relationship
i've seen it happen over and over again
i've lost friends
because of the way they behaved at their
weddings or the way that they a lot of
friendships stop
at weddings it's wild so was what was
like the most stressful thing
or like the most stressful thing for me
was
well i think the number one most
stressful thing for me was
learning that i was not impervious to
wedding stress like i
i did not grow up dreaming about my
wedding i was never
that person so i thought there's no way
that that stress is going to reach me
because my
the the what is the word i'm looking for
um
the importance of it just wasn't the
significance of it wasn't really there
for me
which would make it way more stressful i
would think because you're not like this
is my
you know your lady yeah and i also don't
think i had a clear vision yeah
so i think that to me was that was the
hardest part was when i was like oh i'm
becoming that person that everyone told
me
i would become yeah and i have no
control over it okay
it's just like the wedding is truly
taking over me i'm like possessed by it
right
because it's also it's so daunting like
there's this thing like
where it's so far away and there's
always something to do
yeah it's like a full-time job that you
pay to do
correct that's what a wedding feels like
to me and and
everyone's going to have that one friend
that makes it about them or these
parents who are like we're not going to
fly
like it's just there's so much that's
out of your control yeah
and you're dealing with so many
personalities like it would just
well i think that you're dealing with
personalities and also
for some reason weddings bring to the
fore
all of the dynamics in your life
friendship dynamics
family dynamics that you're you're just
not in a position
prior to getting engaged to even have to
confront those things in your life
that is it a wedding holds a mirror up
to all of your shit you know like to me
when i was planning a wedding when i was
engaged like
a year and a half ago i'd be like wait
are we still am i still friends with
this person i fucking can't stand this
why am i even still i'm inviting this
person my wedding right i had to face
that like my dad died he's gonna walk me
down the aisle i'm like i have to face
the grief of my dad i haven't processed
this like
it made me it's like putting benzyl
peroxide on your skin to like bring all
the zits out
that's exactly what it is and you're
like wait a second i thought i had saved
more money and waited
absolutely hold on yeah it makes you
confront your finances it makes you
confront your friendships it makes you
not only deal with your own family but
deal with your partner's family
on a level you never ever wanted to even
know their friends their friends
yeah absolutely you know we have to have
you know tim who i've you know
went on that rum springer with it's just
like i'm going i have to invite my ex
and you're like what like it's just it's
just so wild how much it brings up
that's so true
yeah and like i think for i think my
i think i was very surprised at how
it also i mean the hardest part too is
like how do you and your partner
handle outside infiltration
do you guys have good boundaries or do
you
like let people invade the fort and
if you don't sync up in that way you
have to be on the same
team it has to be you against the world
instead of you against each other which
is a good metaphor
for marriage um but again
it's not necessarily something you know
about each other yeah until you have to
go through it and then you're
it's holding a mirror up to your
relationship as well of like okay this
is
these are our values this is how we deal
with conflict this is how we cope with
stress what's the number one mistake
brides make do you think if you had to
pick um
getting married
i mean look here's what i'll say as
someone that made
someone that made a television show
about a girl that did not want to get
married
um and the guy did it was a little
gender reversal was very subversive you
guys missed all that when you were
hating on it um i love that thank you i
watched it
um as someone that was i have seen five
divorces by the time i was 15
is very precarious with money like can't
imagine the idea of spending a bunch of
money on a wedding sounds crazy
don't want to put my friends through it
because it's also what i do for a living
like
my friends work on the weekends like the
idea of me having a wedding on a
saturday or a sunday like
half my friends won't be able to come
because they're doing stand up they're
like i'm not gonna give up
msg show to come to your wedding like
i'll come to the next one
right now like so like my friends
probably won't even be there i have like
a bunch of family members that i don't
have a lot of family like
i don't have a lot of family either like
at all and um
but i was talking to kevin christie a
dear friend of mine and he goes
no no the wedding's not for you like
it's not only it's not for you but the
point of a wedding
is so that all your friends bear witness
to what you're doing and hold you
accountable
so and i was like that kind of makes
sense dude that's why i'm not going to
cheat on somebody because it's like
my friend spent all this money on the
wedding like what am i gonna do i i
would really agree with that advice
i think that there's a lot of
accountability that comes with we've
already shown
them to your wedding we all know we're
stated
we hoteled and you're slammed married
and so next time we're out at a bar
and you decide you want to go flirt with
that girl i'm gonna be like no bitch
we spent two thousand dollars right
remember that she's
you're not flirting with her you're
staying married so it's also a way that
your friends can
keep you in line and and witness you
moving to this more mature place in your
life and you can't really have as many
like secrets or like secret life
you know yeah and like i i needed to
hear that
but then yeah it was just and the
wedding planning for me just
it got really stressful i think mostly
because i was like i didn't have someone
to walk me down the aisle and the idea
of picking
i was like i'm gonna hurt so many
people's feelings if i don't pick i got
really into that the bridesmaid stuff
the maid of honor like i don't want to
and i got really paralyzed but like fine
by this person i have to fight this
person
and i was like i'm just gonna have to
like draw so many boundaries and it
seems exhausting i'm gonna have to tell
this person they're not invited i'm
tough
like i just was like i don't want to
deal with all this because i know people
are gonna take it personally so either
my wedding has to be nobody or like 500
people
because i'm so codependent you know and
uh
and then everyone's like solution for
that when you say you don't want a big
wedding is you're like why don't you
just go down to city hall
and i'm like no i want me to go downtown
i don't want to be in like a
government like what am i going to go
yeah i'm going to get a ticket
go to the dmv yeah like no we're all
trying to avoid that as much as possible
yeah i don't i i i can hardly go to jury
like i don't go to jail absolutely you
want me to go to jury duty
to go sign this contract it just sounds
like the least romantic thing ever but
then you also realize if you're not
willing to go downtown for someone you
probably shouldn't marry them
well that's that yeah that's interesting
to to be like yeah
can you go through this like very no
frills
process with this person and like still
be like i'm obsessed with you i love you
about this yeah
yeah and that was tricky for me why also
can't
uh and in your experience have you seen
success with this why why
i think i'm gonna propose the next time
i'm very hell-bent on being i get that
the proposer sure do you hear about
people that have proposed to their guy
yeah i think so i think it's becoming
more common i don't know anyone who's
done it yeah right
how do you get a guy if you're proposing
to him um
like a hamburger
[Music]
like say a hammer something like meat
based like a nice flashlight
jerky or some tools
like yeah
i would think because i've been thinking
about this a lot i was thinking of watch
that's because you know yeah i also
watch it because i'm watching you now
i'm watching yeah i see you yeah
your life is over your time is up on
this earth
you're with me now i mean you could do
like a machete or like a vintage sword
or something
or like sword no no no no it's like
it's a little cosplay and it's oh you're
right you're right you're right i'm
getting
most women that are murdered are
murdered by their spouses but if
i if i'm going to get murdered
by way of sword i mean at least there's
a good story there
all i care about is that my funeral is
funny like if my my funeral better be
the funniest thing i've ever done like i
have lots of plans for my funeral what
are some
they're gonna carry my body in on a um
like a crane and i want them to lower my
body down
yeah and i'm going to make all my
friends very like a pop star
like descending from the ceiling it's
going to be like a prank
and then i have a girl that looks
exactly like me who lives in portland
her name is april i mean like
exactly like me so she's going to walk
just kidding
just kidding again she actually is dead
and double kidding and then someone
kills her
at my funeral oh my god
this is like a tony and tina's wedding
like this is very elaborate
i think about my funeral all the time
wow really
wedding i can't i can't i'm like
constantly trying to forget death
so also i the dude i'm dating is a rock
climber i got him a rock
wall so i did get him a rock i mean like
80 rocks
um but the question is what do you do if
you propose to the guy
and then i feel like you got him a rock
wall yeah like i think you did
it like you got him enough yeah yeah
yeah
but i shouldn't be teaching i shouldn't
be helping him learn how to climb away
that means he could get away but then
also could like
plummet to his death that's like there
is a threat of like
i shouldn't go anywhere in all the way
full misery oh did you roll your ankle
boo on the on that loose uh
rock wall hold on when you were scaling
yeah yeah
how cute am i okay i'm going to do that
i'm going to do that what do you think a
man's
role in the wedding is i feel like this
is my
sexist tell me if i'm sexist i
from what i've seen the reason guys are
so like
like furtive about proposals and
controlling and about the proposal
uh is that of course we've been
conditioned to believe that the man
needs to do it but also that's his last
chance to really weigh in on much that's
what a guy told me so i was like
one of my friends uh dudes did this
elaborate proposal it was so
unnecessarily elaborate and annoying she
had to like miss work it was like i was
like dude you gotta we can't
we had like five friends taking off work
doing like pranks and
jumping out of bushes and i was like
dude she's not gonna want any of this
and he was like this is the last thing i
get to do
that's interesting i've never heard that
theory i mean
his his wife's a very good friend of
mine and he's right i mean he's he's
right
he never got to he never got to do it
yeah i never got to make a decision yeah
yeah he knew
he knew um i yeah i think that
where do i stand on this i mean for me i
definitely
i think like whatever this is kind of
like going deep but like i went to art
school and
i have always enjoyed aesthetic and like
i didn't real i've never been an event
planner i'm very disorganized like i
didn't think
i had that in me but i do care about the
way things look and with weddings
especially with like toxic wedding
culture you are told to like
get super super granular attention to
detail
you know what do you want your wedding
to say about you so it's very easy to
get caught up
but everyone's wasted in the first 30
minutes who cares
absolutely well that is a lesson that i
learned is who cares but
as you spend more and more money you're
going oh well i'm spending money so
therefore
i i care about the thing i'm spending
money on like you almost get into this
place
you're literally and emotionally
invested you are emotionally investing
so when someone else tries to weigh in
even if they are on paper 100
right great opinions great ideas
it becomes like you're taking away from
this thing that i'm investing in
so like i just don't just stay in your
lane i don't even want
a better idea right now because i've
gone too far down the line
yeah with this idea yeah and i'm
consciously
going into the dark deep end yes like i
can see it happening i can see myself
falling down the well but there's this
part of me that's like just
let me fall because this is the only
time in my life that i'm
going to it's i'm given social and
societal
permission to fall so just let me do it
and it's interesting like with my
wedding i mean
i definitely had people who were trying
to help me like my
my husband's parents were trying to help
and i was like i am woman hear me roar
like get the fuck
you get very territorial it is really
like on from a primordial sense it is
a a ritual that is very close in our
brain to like nesting you know
and you have the matriarch and you're
nesting and this is the next stage of
your life and when people come in and
meddle it's very much like no bitch this
is my territory i also think that
probably on some like
subconscious level weddings are so
patriarchal in so many ways that you're
like this is kind of the one thing
i get to have agency over was there
anything that was in the wedding that
you were like this is antiquated like
the
yes did you change things um
i didn't i kind of feel like tradition
is helpful
because it gives you a structure a
structure and a schedule
um or not schedule like um yeah it gives
you a structure and it gives you kind of
like
something to work with like it's kind of
a blueprint
um but they're definitely i think when
you're
merging backgrounds traditions get a
little more confusing because like for
me
i grew up i am jewish but i didn't grow
up religious and i grew up in texas
and then my partner grew up in a
jewish enclave on long island and grew
up solely
because yeah went to so many bar
mitzvahs so many weddings done a very
specific
jewish way and for me i didn't grow up
with that so
there were certain things or even like
you know doing the um oh my god i can't
even think this is what it's called
oh that please that that is one of the
scariest things i've ever done when they
put you up in the chair
and funny and it never looks fun to me
it is not it looks like the bride's
sliding out i was sliding and i could
see
my face angling towards the ground i was
like this is it and also i was in a
very tight corseted type dress and i was
like i actually have
no way of stopping this if i fall like i
can't move my legs
i can barely breathe these people are so
old these people yeah
their arms are so weak what's it when
they at jewish weddings when they hold
the bride up in the
and the groom right yeah they're in the
chair and then you hold on to the napkin
everyone is having so much fun except
the bride i feel
every wedding i've gone to the the if
your dress is binding
at all at least like the guys there they
look scared no
it was not fun in fact at the beginning
of my show
in our opening credits there is a quick
shot of me
holding on for dear life to the chair
and just like
mouth a gape just yeah truly terrified
but all i was saying about tradition is
that
with the signing of the ketubah that was
something that really like meant a lot
to him
and i was like why do we have to do this
i just want to like go to my rehearsal
dinner and he's like we have to sign
it right now and i'm like but we invited
all these people and we spent all this
money i just want to go to my party
i just want to i just want to go he
wanted me because
he knows you're going to be super famous
one day and he's going to sell that
signature on ebay
i'm like that's not a tradition well
yeah but um
yeah now i'm separated i have lots of
what
do you talk have you talked about that
or i have a little bit just it's it's
somewhat fresh how long were you married
um four years
we were together for ten that's a
huge success we have to always remember
that marriage was invented when the life
expectancy of human beings was 30 to 35
years old yeah
okay like we're meant to have a couple
relationships before we die if you meet
your
um love of your life when you're 18 and
stay together forever
god's speed you're fucking weird and
uncle they've been together
cool yeah get the pressure a lot of
pressure
high speed wi-fi see if it sticks um but
yeah so if that's your thing like that's
awesome you won the lottery like chelsea
lynn who was on here like she's been
with her guy for
18 years or something but incredible but
were not designed
i don't think when this institution was
invented they would have said forever
had they known that we were going to
invent antibiotics and vitamins and all
this stuff that kept us alive till we
were 100.
yeah you know so 14 years that's i mean
that's
longer than most marriages well i'm not
going to lie i think that the wedding
planning process
did do lasting damage i am one of those
and do you think it's because
of of the behavior or because of what
was revealed during the planning process
what was revealed during the planning
process because you get to know each
other
super well yeah yeah and we
yeah we were having fights that i
i yeah i mean just like the type of
fighting because the irony is you were
already married
you know like when yeah you're together
10 years you're married
yeah i mean there's your especially if
you're living together you're already
legally part i mean it's already going
to be
we were together sit yeah six years and
then yeah we were married four yeah ten
total ten total i mean i don't want to
be making that distinction
that yeah that it is gonna be a
nightmare regardless like when people
are like we live together but we're not
married it's like dude once you live
together been together for a while and
our messenger bought couches together
and have a dog together like you're
married like this breakup is gonna be
just as hard
without the legal zoom of it all yeah
yeah i mean
yeah it's funny because when you know
now now the show i don't know when this
comes out but
the show you know on netflix is called
the wedding coach and it's like oh i'm
going to be like a divorced wedding
coach
but actually i actually think it like to
me it's like dude
you should try i do think that's right
if i had a if
if you hadn't gone through what you've
gone through in the adversity and
like you're the only person i want to
listen who's like don't make the same
mistake i made
thanks for saying that i also feel that
way and i also think unfortunately in
our culture like the wedding is
very separate from the marriage and if
there's anything i can impart it's like
put your relationship
first and do what's right by your
relationship not
it should be about the marriage family
not yes it needs to just be about the
two of you being
like united against the world but then
you also have to get your shit together
so for me
when i started planning a wedding i
realized like i have a lot more work to
do on my codependence shit because i'm
like i don't want this person to be mad
at me or like if i don't
i don't want this person to have to
spend this much money on this but you
know i know they're not gonna
they're not gonna like this place and
this person hates the sun and this
person hates the mountains like i was
thinking about
saying that when i was like picking
venues and i'm like ah so-and-so's not
gonna want to drive all this way or oh
she's got kit we should have child care
at the wedding like i just spent all
this time hoping that the guests were
gonna have
a good time and not be mad at me and i
was like i need to like do some work on
myself because i'm gonna have to keep
setting boundaries up until the day this
happens
the day it's actually happening when my
whatever weird
you know cousin who i can't stand wants
to talk to me and have to be like give
me a second like i'm gonna have to do
this
all uh up until this thing and i need to
get stronger at this
do you also feel like because of what
you do as a performer
like do you do you feel like wedding
attention
you already kind of get that there's a
little bit of that like
like this is not i mean i yes i've
talked about this um
before not on the podcast but you know i
we do get to get in hair and makeup a
lot and dress up a lot and you know i
think that a lot of people
you know don't like the idea of me like
dressing up and taking a bunch of photos
i'm like i have to do this every day and
i'm actually like
i i it was one of the things i was like
about my wedding
how am i shy all of a sudden like how am
i you know and then i think a big thing
is i was i was also trepidatious as a
comic that my vows were just
they were just gonna turn into a fucking
roast and make things awkward i did that
once as a wedding officiant
i like sort of went a little roasty and
i was like oh not the place not the
place
you know so i'm like worried that my va
his vows would be like amazing and
emotional and i would just be like
this is what happened at my wedding and
because i set a rule i was like we
cannot
because he's in comedy as well i was
like we cannot have like sticky
vows like we have to speak for mine
would just be like
savage roast yeah no no i mean yes that
too
of like just like making it good for the
audience
well that's what's funny is that i set
this hard and fast rule
and still somehow ended up
doing like a comedy performance and then
his were so he completely listened to me
his were so genuine
he had some stuff written down on paper
he actually threw the paper
with tears and was just like speaking
from the heart and i was like oh my and
i had to go second
and i was like oh no oh buddy i didn't
take my own
advice i didn't do the exercise that i
put in place
was it awkward i mean mine was still i
think it was still
sweet enough but like he really like did
the thing that i
said we should do and then i like only
did it about fifty percent
and it was still pretty jokey and i'll
tell you something in fact i use one of
the jokes from my vows in my
step in my stand-up now which is crazy
so you got something out of it i
i want to go over a couple things
complaints that i have about weddings
and i want you to tell me if i'm being
a brat or histrionic or if these are
fair complaints
um when weddings are on either
valentine's day or new year's eve
people throw their weddings on holidays
i i
love a new year's eve just because i
think people are kind of looking for
plans something to do something to not
have to think about but i feel like
people are coming to new year's eve to
get fucking
wasted but you have to factor that in
you can't be like a dry wedding on new
year's
you have to be like i'm gonna i'm gonna
make sure you guys party but it's also
going to be chilly willy
and then i like you know okay it is me
chilly willy but also
you know like i don't like going to a
wedding being like i have to wear a long
sleeve
dress with like wool under bruise i
see i kind of romanticize the world old
weddings aren't fun
well yeah you have to get you have to
get enough heaters
if you're going to do outdoor or you
just do an indoor venue i don't know i'm
going to lose my shawl
i mean when you go to a wedding and they
have a basket full of like pashminas
you're like oh fuck
i know it's gonna be a chilly willy
wedding i spent all this money on this
dress and i'm gonna be chilly the whole
time yeah
i think that you have to make sure to
just have adequate
emily's like stop saying chili willy
please god
um valentine's day wedding i've heard of
it
i mean if that's what does it for you
go for it but i mean if you i don't
it's a little corny but also yeah you're
right it is more but there is something
but also it's kind of there's something
to be said there's somebody said for me
like we're gonna have to we're gonna
take valentine's day off your fucking
plate yeah i like that too and i also
think like
february 14th it's pretty cold out it's
also it's probably
really cheap i would think to get
valentine's day because it is so cold
even though it's like the day of life oh
yeah you know when someone gets married
on like a
on like a friday they got a deal yeah
yeah
you're like okay you got half off right
it's like tuesday in the day of winter
even if it is like february 14th that's
still like
you like you're doing okay like that was
a smart budgeting decision
we now take a break uh from me talking
to hear more of me talking
ah everyone's favorite but it's gonna be
a little more scripted
and if i'm an interrupt it's going to be
myself maybe i'll bring that nerve to
you
so you stop i should bring the nerf gun
to ads and shoot you
i did that on purpose to see if you
would stop when somebody here's what
you're supposed to do when someone
interrupts you right so start talking
oh i am i need you i can't hear you
no no you just do this so interrupt me
while i'm talking okay so
it's actually impossible to interrupt
you when you're talking i've tried for
years
um you i'm trying to interrupt you wait
oh wait no
this is the first you're i'm trying to
teach you you're trying to teach me how
to interrupt
we need less interrupting okay can we
get to the ad here
oh my god i completely forgot we were
doing an ad
i just thought
um okay so here's the thing i am we are
going to read this verbatim because
ritual
uh we normally talk about their
multivitamin which i have been on for
literally years they have a new product
that we're just going to read it
because i love it so much that i'm going
to start being like and it cures leprosy
no it doesn't yeah yeah it's sort of
like maybe um
opinions placebo effect um so
ritual i'm obsessed with everything they
do
um their team of scientists hello
harvard
reimagine protein from the ground up and
inside out
from how it's made to who it's for
and why it's needed the result is a
delicious plant-based protein
offered in three premium formulations
for distinct life stages and unique
nutrient needs
same high standards approach and
commitment to traceability that ritual
is known
for i always say that about ritual can
you read them no one for traceability
sorry i thought you just wanted my two
cents thoughtful no i'm gonna start
paying you two cents if you keep
making jokes like that thoughtful
purpose-built formulation
clean plant-based formulas specifically
created to support
nutrient needs of different life stages
18 plus
pregnancy and postpartum please please
please 50 plus no no no
so why not shake up your ritual whitney
to make trying something new less scary
ritual offers a money-back guarantee if
you're not 100
in love plus whitney's listeners get 10
off during their first three months just
visit ritual.com
whitney to add essential protein today
that's ritual.com
whitney and i know i'm not allowed to
make claims that aren't necessary
i'm just saying we're cutting look at me
they're going to pay us not to advertise
them if that's how we do it
now we're going to talk about
it make it in bed i never sleep naked
crawl up your butt
like dicks i don't know bugs how big is
your butthole
jesus best fiends crawling up your butt
there
brook linen is truly i
am a such a snob when it comes to
betting brook linen i had
a brand i was using before and i was
like i will never switch i will never
switch
and then you and benton were like try
book brook linen
and it's again it is
i i didn't want to be wrong but it is
such a game changer it has something for
everything you need
uh refresh launching new products like
sometimes you need to refresh your bed
like excite yourself so they have cozy
robes
loungewear i love wearing loungewear
they are so confident in their core
products they come with a 365 day
warranty unlike this podcast you will
not get your time or money back
and all uh the fans are so confident too
they've
received over 75 000 five-star reviews
they make me feel rich even though i
live in a studio apartment there you go
what i'm saying there you go i don't
know how we top that endorsement all
right so give yourself the comfort
refresh you deserve and get it for less
at brooklyn go to brooklyn.com
and use promo code whitney to get twenty
dollars off with a minimum purchase of a
hundred dollars that's b
r o o k l i n e n dot com and enter
promo code whitney for twenty dollars
off with a minimum purchase of a hundred
dollars that's brooklyn.com promo code
um okay how many parties
do i have to attend so my thing is i'll
come to two out of the five
engagement party wedding shower
bachelorette
wedding rehearsal dinner sorry rehearsal
wedding and then day after brunch i
never fuck with the day after brunch
really no i don't want to face
anybody i don't want anyone to see me in
the daylight i killed i
i killed at the wedding i'm gonna just
leave i'm gonna leave on a high note wow
when you come in the next morning and
you're just like ugh
i love i love brunch i any kind of
brunch
day after brunch no particular stuff
everyone's like drinking mimosas you're
already like puking from the night
before and they like
throw the most in your face it's very
weird as the bride because everyone
knows that you got
plowed the night before and so you have
to like
look all your relatives in the eye and
they're like how was it
you know you're like okay um yeah that
that's absolute hell
but i still have like a sideways tiara
yeah like the bride always still has
like
two crusty tendrils oh god tendrils just
they're still just like random like
little spider legs from the eyelashes
yes exactly
not great yeah not great not great i i
but why
how many parties is when is it getting
tacky
how many parties am i expected to go to
i mean expected to go to
whatever works for you i have zero
expectations if i go to the engagement
my thing is i'll come to the engagement
party bachelorette if we're real tight
and then the wedding i didn't have an
engagement party and i didn't have a
bridal shower i kind of feel like
bachelorette is the only one
what is shit difference with between the
bridal shower and the fucking same thing
bridal shower is like fake dignified
whereas bachelorette is like
honest uh
like what is the registry uh why am i
getting you a present at the fucking
bridal shower and then i'm also getting
you something from the registry can i
just
give you a gift certificate to your
registry i don't even know how many
gifts do you fucking
don't even know yeah because i didn't do
that and also
i've always been confused by that i
always just gave one gift but maybe i'm
an asshole
i have a friend who uh uh got
made us do a registry from a bunch of
stuff at like some fancy place like
neiman marcus or something
and she returned it all and got to bed
my thing is if i get you
a present on your registry i better see
it when i come over
oh sure the platter better be used
better the vas
better be out yeah if i get you
something on the registry and i go to
your house and you've sold it or given
it away or it's in a fucking drawer
you're going to get an earful do you
really like look to be like yeah
if i spent 20 fucking what 200
on a gravy boat you better be serving me
gravy gravy in the boat in the boat
because i want to prove i want you to
know i got it for you
right and when i come over i expect to
see my work bitch we're having
biscuits yes i like to i like to see i
don't care
if you have a gluten allergy put them
out and we're gonna gravy them
my the numbers of strings that are
attached to the gifts i give
yeah i need to know you're using it i
need to know you're liking it
because but we're buying shit for your
kitchen
that's the part yeah it is a little
weird because
because then i do the math where i'm
like this is like a two hundred thousand
dollar wedding why the fuck am i buying
you a gravy but you it's you're doing
funny
it feels like you can afford this you
guys are solid yeah i feel like you're i
feel like you should be giving us
yeah give us the fucking gravy bowl yeah
like when you get a really expensive
wedding that has a really expensive
registry i think it's tacky
it is i also am a little bit where do
you stand
on uh in lieu of gifts please make a
donation
i'm i don't i mean
there's so honestly there's so many
things i'm not with it you don't get to
decide
where i donate all of it is so flawed
what if i don't want to give kids i
don't need kids to be able to read
right maybe that's not what i want read
across america i don't want to donate to
that
but if i don't want to donate to that
there's other causes that
i care about more and some of these
charities are fucking scams well
sometimes they do
say yes and sometimes they do say like
make a donation at a charity of your
choice
but no no but but if if you say that
okay you then
are not allowed to and this has happened
to me go hey we see that you haven't
donated wait who the
fuck oh my god i just got just
happened for how much i hate yes because
you have a year to buy it followed up
oh yeah follow up with me that wait like
they're right
or something okay still we see you
haven't donated yet and i was like yeah
okay
that you're not so horrified um
i would cut them off yeah oh i didn't oh
i didn't so dumb i have lost
many friends well they needed to go
going insane at their wedding they
needed to go
that's really wild to like just check up
and be like
hey where did you where'd you spend your
money
max amount of money you a bride can
expect
their bridesmaid to spend on a dress
when is it too far
i have a friend who was um asked to buy
specific prada shoes that were like
seven hundred and fifty dollars
psychopath she
had to tell her like i can't do that and
then the bride used it against her and
said but
i flew you to st bart for the
bachelorette and she's
does this bride have an opening for a
new friend i will buy those products
shoes right now
i know yeah but my friend was like okay
thank you for that but also i
can't spend seven hundred and fifty
dollars no one can or shows yeah
yeah wow i like it when brides for
bridesmaids do
i don't care what your dress is just all
green or everyone like in different
shades of green
i use or red or whatever okay that used
to be
what i thought i wanted yeah but then
you realize you're actually putting the
onus on them to figure it out
so there is a freedom in saying this is
the dress
and yes it's a bridesmaid's dress and
yes you're never going to wear you're
going to get flattered in it but
whatever even if that
it's always like quite dumpy and in a
jewel tone nobody needs
to wherever but like what mahogany it's
not to do a plug but there is this
there's probably a couple companies like
this but there's one called the zazi
and it's just like affordable it's a
bunch of different types of dresses in
every color under the sun
and i just appreciate that they're like
we know
that this sucks for the bridesmaids
we're gonna make it as easy for you as
possible
a friend of mine uh uh joanna august she
makes these bridesmaids dresses
and like they're like um
i'm trying to think of how to say it
they've got like straps where you can ch
everyone can look different
it's almost like a grecian gown i know
i've seen that it comes in the color so
everyone can kind of like do what works
for their body type
right you know that's kind of like a
zazy also it's like they can customize
it and then you can wear it after the br
the freaking wedding at some point yeah
i i do not subscribe to you're gonna
wear it again i just
right up top you just take that dick
you're gonna have to yeah take the dick
in the butt
i was gonna say mouth but okay yeah
let me know if you need to know what
you're in for um get ready to use a lot
of gifts and take it to the butt
destination wedding how far is too far
to expect your friends to travel because
my thing is if you're gonna have a
destination wedding in fucking
morocco only the weirdos are gonna show
up
not the people with jobs or people with
kids like your friends you have to be
ready for only the weirdos on your list
to show up oh
see i feel like if you do a destination
wedding there is sort of a subtext
there of we don't really want a lot of
people to come and i think that
has to be a choice that you're
comfortable with right and i think it's
kind of a beautiful thing like
i like the idea of like weeding out as
many people as possible
and just being like close people in my
life
hope you can come to tulum or whatever
it is
but if you can't that's okay too right i
think a lot of this stuff too is
indicative of how strong your
relationship is
because if you really are like psyched
and in love
and like this is taking things to
another level for us
and we're so just like enveloped in each
other yeah
you're really not going to give a shit
if anyone one person can't make it
because it really i think it's actually
a great test of how strong your
relationship is see i'm an asshole i'm
like
i need everyone to come to the wedding
because i don't want to have to tell you
how it was
okay like you should have been i don't
have time to go
i should do a lot of reasons so how was
the wedding it's like i don't just watch
the
look at my instagram i don't know i
don't have to recap the whole thing but
you wouldn't you would just like post a
few things and people will be like oh
cool look
great but i i do like that a friend of
mine got married in italy in a place
called ravello
beautiful scourge i mean i had altitude
sickness when they puked the entire time
but it was beautiful
i think that i really liked what what
she did which she did it on labor day
and told us
literally two years in advance she was
like save the date beautifully and we
all turn it into like a trip
it's a bunch of work two years in
advance that's hard to well she said
save the date
like this late not this labor day next
labor day right and
uh so everyone was able to like plan a
vacation around it
right and what people like went to
florence first and then came down
florida everyone's gonna be pissed to go
to ravello yeah it totally but it was
like
it was not just i'm flying out for two
days and spending all this money
ridiculous
and uh and that was like super cool like
yeah i love that well that's i think for
a destination wedding where you have a
like a
decent number of guests i think that's
kind of the that sounds like the most
considerate way to pull that off
and then also what's the what's the what
is the proper etiquette of
can you bring a guest like the no bling
no bring thing
i'm sort of on that but also i'm very
anti-single stable if you put me at the
fucking singles at the children's table
it is so
like when there's just a table full of
single people put us with the people
that have figured it out that have
friends that are single
that you could set me up with don't put
me with all the pigs if you can swing it
financially yeah i think it means if you
can
swing it if you can allow someone to
bring whoever they want whether it's a
romantic partner or a friend
but they're just not allowed in the
photos in some bb fucking mini skirt if
you bring some
horror okay do i mean like they i don't
want to go through my wedding photos and
like
be like who was this random whore like
you know she shouldn't be in all the
photos like
whoever the date you do bring that just
make sure they know their place
that's all i'm saying like they can't be
in the pictures
on our show i bring a different friend
to every wedding i go to
and i call them my plus one and i'm like
this it really is me living out of
fantasy because there have been so many
weddings i've been invited to
i didn't get a plus one or i did but i
didn't really like want to bring like
a dude i was dating i just wanted to
bring like a good friend a friend oh
going with
friends is the most fun and it's like
not customary so
yeah i was like i have to sort of like
take back the plus one on my show but it
is i
i would imagine if it's like expensive i
totally get it of course that's right
yeah but i've just seen some like
ratchet plus ones roll into weddings and
i'm like oh
yeah i mean this person's ruining all
the photos there is a risk
for sure but i definitely think like if
you're
comfortable doing it it's it is a great
way to go for your guests it's very
considerate i think
it doesn't even mean they're gonna take
you up on it it's just like nice to give
them that freedom
i'm okay so here here's another thing
how okay i'm gonna ask you a couple like
i'm doing like a speed round
of like wedding etiquette questions that
i do not know the fucking answer with
um what the fuck when brides you're not
supposed to wear white to a wedding but
bride sometimes don't only wear white
now it's very in vogue to wear other
colors and
this was the pilot of the whitney show
by the way where um uh
uh i showed up to a wedding and i was
wearing like butter yellow yeah i
remember
and then this fucking bride had a butter
yellow vera winged and i was just like
no no no no no the you didn't follow the
fucking rules
i followed the rules i didn't wear white
if you're the bride's not gonna wear
white you need to send out like an
email or uh i think butter yellow is
totally fair game
you only get one color that you get to
like take over
and it even stops because she had like
beautiful darker skin i looked like i
was
sick and had scurvy but you know it was
my friend had a red wedding dress and
plenty of people wearing
red at her wedding and there was no part
of me that was like you're trying to
upstage her i'm like
no like the bride stands out no i'm
bleeding fucking wedding dress
but also what um uh you know what i love
a friend of mine had an all-white
wedding
and i loved it it was so beautiful i
mean it kind of looked like a weird
scientology yeah yeah yeah we went into
the river and they blessed us
and then we all had to fuck each other
um but there was something
so clean and beautiful about it because
you know people you know did they serve
red wine
no no oh i don't know that's a really
good question yeah there was no salsa
there was no yes sketchy foods but there
was something so
beautiful about it that everyone was
like knew what to wear
and it was like you could be in
sweatpants you could be in again it's
kind of fun
like everyone and everyone's version of
what it was just like cool yeah
like all the photos are so cool like i
don't know yeah i was into that
yeah i was very into that um maximum
number of bridesmaids you can have and
do the number of grooms men have to
match the number of
bridesmaids because grooms by the time
they i feel like
get engaged they've lost half their
friends so i feel like grooms normally
don't have enough friends
oh see i had the opposite i feel like
yeah so many friends from childhood all
of them
like wanting to all grow up together
same same posse
but um i don't think it matters at all i
also don't think you need an even number
um i think i had seven bridesmaids and
i was really stressed i was like maybe
you should have eight you choose who
walks down the aisle with who the
bridesmaids in the groom
no wedding coordinator did that stuff oh
but a lot of this stuff
i'm realizing like it's just it's so
interesting like you would think
that after having a wedding i would be
more like invested in the way to do
things but it's actually
very much the opposite for me i'm like i
wouldn't say
disillusioned but like definitely
i'm just very like do whatever you want
to do
and like really make sure you're doing
that and you're not
failing like there's like the seating
chart my thing was like i'm just not
doing this
if people can see whatever the fuck they
want you're adults sit with who you want
to sit with i'm not going to be like
you know what i think um uncle rick
shouldn't sit next to marty because they
can talk about cars
right like when people get in there and
like oh and this person just went
through a divorce and this person just
went through a divorce let's sit them
next to each other right and then when
they're at the table they're like
why did they put us together together
like what is this formula and what it
why am i
all these like total betas they always
put me next to you
you find out how you're perceived by
your friend by who they put you with yep
but here's the thing i'm the person that
all my friends are like oh she can sit
with anybody so they always put me with
the fucking duds
because they're like she can do anything
right and hold her own
and then you become responsible for like
making the table fun because no one else
is funny yeah when i'm like why
am i fucking here who are all these
people well you're you're i don't know
these people playing a very important
role
you're making that that the party takes
and then i'm you're the mascot at the
table
or they'll put me next to just the
loudest most obnoxious people
they're like she'll do fine here she's
in good comfort
yeah right i'm with like the loud uncle
and like that she's with her people the
stepmom and like the ex-girlfriend like
i'm always with the like monsters i'm
like oh fuck man
one time i was sat at the kid's table
and it was outside the venue like it was
like
it was like it was downtown at the
cicada or something it was some place
downtown and
and there was like the whole wedding and
then it was like over a tent and then
there was a table we were outside
we really wouldn't even let us in they
were like oh we'll just put them back
there
the only like main rule i have that i
would really
try to stick to is i think that when it
comes to
food i think quantity is more important
than quality
interesting because i think a lot of
people at weddings
are dealing with like social anxiety or
social awkwardness
and i think that we typically want to
either a eat our feelings in those
situations
or we just need something to do so we
look busy
yeah so chasing down a cater waiter
going back to the buffet
like these are things you do to keep
business also we've been here since
years and we're fucking hungry there's
also that there's oh of course this is
the bride's not eating doesn't mean
we're not eating right but i'm saying
like i think your hunger is almost at
like an
all-time high like special levels i've
been dancing to brick house for their
week two hours
yeah oh i hate that i know i have some
wedding songs i cannot oh my god
brick house really rough like all
september please uh
how does it go it oh god
like most annoying weddings who is that
for who is that for
um is it like what what how you can only
step touch to that also it hasn't
been a rel in the rotation for 30 years
like we've got to update the playlist
and you don't listen to that on your own
that only comes up at weddings it's like
a date of honor you're at a wedding
speech faux pas
have you seen some nasty ones i think
yes i mean the main thing is uh don't i
don't think you should try to make jokes
i think you should try to be really
specific
if i'm your maid of honor okay well
whitney okay
all right well when i yeah all right i
mean you're
you i would say you're an anomaly
don't feel the pressure because uh
you're gonna go to
inevitably jamie fucked everyone in
hollywood but she chose you like when
when a bridesmaid or a groom thinks it's
funny to say like how many people
his homie banged before like it's always
more
or what will happen is if someone's
nervous
they dip into like you know when you
start out and stand up and you were like
like you were just like needlessly crass
like mean or dirty yeah yeah mean or
dirty and anything that they go this
that happens oh sorry go ahead no as you
say anything that um
if a joke doesn't hit it's either an
insult or a lie always right
so that same thing happens i think
especially like yeah a best man for
example
at a wedding at a rehearsal dinner that
i was at um
he was bombing with his like regular i'm
going to use comedy terms with his
regular material
so then he went to mentioning how
the groom used to masturbate on the bed
above him at camp
and every just saying the word
masturbate like really sucked the air
out
and then he was bombing even harder
after that and everyone i mean i i
was sweating watching on there it was
such so
when speeches come up i just cringe i
just brace and like this
is so uncomfortable oh the worst is like
i think a lot of
girls um do this thing where they
oh god this is going to get me in
trouble let me think of how to say it
clickbait well like i've been
yeah we're almost like the thing okay so
here's the thing with best man's
speeches or like any kind of groom
speech
you start to realize like oh they
actually kind of like really know each
other
they can like jab at each other they can
roast each other
there's a closeness there there's a
trust there but then i've noticed a lot
of times
women kind of do this like very
sort of scaled-back measured thing where
they'll be like
you know and lacie you know lacey and i
we always uh we i love our late nights
and you know when we get those cupcakes
and everyone like
dies laughing at cupcakes and you're
like what is go like
why are we being so i don't even know
how to describe
we're also comics we're also asking but
it's also like it's
just like do you know each other like
this is the story
is that you guys like to eat together
like who doesn't fucking eat together
so i don't know like inside jokes or
just like
i don't know my thing is like come to
fucking kill i don't like or
or just be super sincere i also you're
making me think i feel like
having your sister be your maid of honor
i understand why people do it for sure
but it's so much
more fun i feel like when it's one of
your girlfriends who knows you a little
bit differently
but i've also seen a a maid of honor
speech go down
real dark when a drunk sister was like
so i'm gonna make up the names like lucy
here she is
getting engaged two years after i got
engaged
and it it was i i wild and it was like
i moved to la she moves to la i get
engaged he gets engaged he's always done
everything i do like it was like such a
like tense
passive aggressive like it was so
awkward this kind of happened at my
rehearsal dinner
um someone on the groom side of the
family
got up and um started with like light
tears and then it turned into
full-blown like sobbing hysterical and
also made a comment about
how lucky i was to be marrying into his
family
and it was like my family kind of got
offended at that they were like
what about our family like we're he's
lucky to
marry into our family so she was happy
with this one yeah
yeah also she was with this one for a
really really
long time before he came along yeah so
yeah it just got like
very sobby and also
a little like kind of elitist yeah yeah
yeah yeah
so yeah i that was it were these teams
we're getting married yeah exactly we're
merging
um okay so i have this thing where i
feel like
i believe i will have a wedding one day
but
whether there's a groom or not it might
be televised and scripted by me and the
actor will be cast to pretend he's in
love with me and marrying me
your thanksgiving meal was wedding
adjacent and i loved it you know what i
really
do did you feel that when you were there
i yeah
kind of okay like i hope my wedding is
as fun as like when i'll put on like big
dinners and stuff like that's my goal
that's why i think like that's that
should be that should be the pinnacle
like it shouldn't go beyond that and do
you know why
it's manageable and you know why i want
to get married so bad but is that i
want my friends i have so many awesome
friends that i want to hang out with
each other oh yeah
it's more that but i can do that without
signing a contract giving away half my
shit
yeah there's other ways to do that my
favorite part of my wedding was just
everybody i love staying at the same
hotel and like bumping into each other
and like there was a night maybe two
nights before our wedding
where everybody was just getting into
town and there was no plan
so it was just like hey if you've
arrived come meet us at the bar
and we're just gonna be like sitting
around this fire pit and everybody
showed up
and it was just so low pressure there
were no plans
and it was just like it was the best
part of the wedding weekend i thought
was the lack of organization and just
there was something organic about it and
why did you wear a corset
it wasn't a corset it was a dress that
had boning in it so it just kind of
restricts your movements
you were just trying to practice for the
bondage that is
yeah marriage like why it is so funny
because like every girl i know
is like like i'm getting married it's no
big deal and then they get a dress
that's like
physically painful and like
punishing it turns you into a statue you
don't need to get tetanus on your
wedding day like just can we loosen it
up
why does everyone just have to be so
tight and negative
i mean i do love the boob lift element
but yeah i mean the way so what to show
your tits off to your family
yeah it's weird when people have super
sexy wedding dresses i'm like aren't
your parents here
i mean yours probably was like it was it
was tasteful hot yeah it wasn't like
there weren't like some of these wedding
dresses you need to put some pants on
your grandfather rolled in from palm
springs for this
why are you trying to look hot on your
wedding you're never like you never get
to flirt again
like that that is i do agree with that
but i guess you want your pictures to be
it's just all the pit you wanted to be
up just to remind your man
yeah i also lost so much weight it was
so
bad but what i didn't try i was just so
stressed out that i
stopped eating i would have like three
bites of pad thai and be like i'm good
i've never had that in my life where
stress
stopped me from food okay
i know i've talked a lot about my body
hair on this podcast i know talked a lot
about my lover
and his body and his body hair here's
the thing with guys you can't
push something on them because then
they'll just dig in their heels more
like they will never trust you that
their stubble scratches your chin
or that their balls stink i'm like you
because you don't smell them right
you're not close enough
made it so that you could not put your
face in that area because we all know
you would never we would never procreate
so
i like eased him into it you gotta
like you gotta go like i love you but oh
my god like i just discovered these
things they're called we don't they
don't even know what it is manscaped oh
well okay talking about manscape
we've talked about this before you guys
know where i'm going with this from the
originators of the electric
ball hair trimmer they now have the
razor and set
for men to get your trim get you all
trimmed from front to back
ladies you can finally have your razor
back that's the other thing when guys
you know when guys use your razor and
you come in
and it's just like covered in irish
spring and you're like what did you do
like how did you how do you shave your
spring smells so good it does not
you were traumatized sometimes i use it
and smell myself and think
cute boy
oh my god i believe that was oddly oddly
the darkest
by the way no man under 50 uses that
cute man daddy
this is so dark okay manscaped it is
this new product it's an ultra smooth
package it's a three-step
kit okay to make his package the perfect
package step one is the crop exfoliator
you gotta exfoliate there's dead skin
down there there's
funk there's like i don't i don't want
to say i don't want to trigger people
but there's
it's musty down there it sometimes
smells like wharf so you got
you have to exfoliate okay soothes clear
keep the skin around the groin feeling
refreshed
reduce the risk of ingrown hairs in
delicate places which
a girl might think is herpes and not
that's a no-no not close the deal
yeah so this isn't a positive investment
in your future self
then there's the step two with this
which is the crop
gel this is uh see where you're shaving
with your own unique
clear shaving gel just for the groin
for essential oils it's like a spa
treatment every time you shave and it
smells
nice very nice i will go down on you if
you smell like eucalyptus and lavender
only that's all she needs step three
time to shave crop shaver was designed
to shave the groin area with confidence
three precision blades you're not going
to cut your balls you're not going to be
hemorrhaging
you're in the dicks you're not going to
shave half your dick off or whatever
fear you have about all this
um uh get them out because there's
crevices because even when guys
crevices try to save shave you go down
there like you missed a hole yeah
yeah there's like a lot of full there's
a landing strip like on the side of your
balls like it's all you missed a spot a
big spot well i never look i'm just my
eyes are always
sealed shut but i've heard by what
my own cum was that all my own choice
oh you sealed shot by your hand no
when you give blowjobs i've never looked
i can't
why would you look you have to look in
the eyes no you while you're doing it
you're crying sasha
talking about you're crying oh my god
all right go to manscape.com whitney to
get 20 off that's 20
off and free shipping at manscape.com
whitney smooth it out fellas with
manscaped
she will thank you or he will i mean
yeah
yes yeah guys have to lick balls too
so we just talked about how to get your
balls in order
and get them presentable to society and
uh
to stop making your girlfriend think
she's like licking a baby elephant
which we don't ride over here by the way
blue chew blue true
what's the point of having the balls all
clean and shaved if you can't
if you can't get it up and emily and i
with our personalities know what it's
like to watch a man not be able to get
it up
blue chew online prescription service no
visits to the doctor's office
uh no awkward conversation don't even
have to say it out loud
no waiting in line at the pharmacy
perhaps there's a major
no one's going to get on the speaker and
be like we need more bluetooth
ships right to your door we need more
dick medicine
licensed medical providers work with you
to find the right ingredient and
strength for your prescription so you're
not just ordering
i mean i used to date guys that would
order like propecia online from like
reddit and canada don't order your stuff
from sketchy get a licensed medical
provider yeah don't get it from a dot
net
don't like swallowing me neither no
problems here it's chewable oh you guys
don't like halloween
okay don't like swallowing pills
you love smalling pills all you do is
take pills it's kids
see men that you have a problem with uh
blue chews tablets are made in the usa
and as they prepare and ship direct it's
cheaper than a pharmacy
honestly let's put blue true to the test
i'm gonna make my boyfriend listen to us
doing this ad
right after taking a blue chew well i'm
in it so he's obviously gonna be excited
he does love you it's weird
okay can you read the green and not a
shrill way okay
you say that okay i'm just thinking so
we don't lose any make people more
people think they have e.d than do
so if you could benefit from extra
confidence when it's time to perform
visit bluechew.com for more details and
important safety information
and we've got a special deal for our
listeners try blue chew free when you
use our promo code whitney at checkout
just pay five dollar shipping that's
bluechew.com promo code whitney to
receive your first
month free and we thank bluechu for
sponsoring the podcast
that's a whole month of sexin for free
you're like who has sex more than once a
month
month my god whore
okay so my deal is i do not
contra i know i look gorgeous you do in
this uh
sort of weird moments stiff lace
mormon come stand uh gown it's like um
yeah it's like mormon what's the
princess from the mario brothers
uh peach princess peas peach it's mormon
princess is that what's happening it's
also it doesn't zip in the back properly
because it was made for like a child
with scoliosis
so i can't really get this on but i want
a wedding dress that is not white and
every time i
like go for that people don't like it
they're not happy about it i brought
some wedding dresses that i
would like and i want to see if you
think it's a good idea okay
and benton is going to weigh in also
okay so i picked some dresses some of
these were pulled from when i was
engaged
okay a couple years ago i added a couple
more
these are going on my wedding vision
board number one and just
i i like a pop of color
i want to be that fun bride all right
number one
boom this is a extravaganza of
long-sleeve tulle with a bunch of
flowers on it
all over it and i think it is beautiful
right and if you don't like it you're a
psychopath
she looks like a like a memorial you
know people lay flowers on graves two
beautiful brides
oh like when when someone um
dies in a car accident you just keep
laying flowers in one spot
on the side of the freeway yeah she's
clearly by an ocean
um so that it so this doesn't feel
weddingy
it feels it feels like a like a garden
party if you're having a
baby shower um what it feels like that's
what i feel like if someone's taken
away a baby shower if someone showed up
in this to a baby shower i would call
the police
no it would be their baby shower oh okay
that would be crazy
i'm kind of into it it's kind of like
claude monet but make it fashion
yeah kind of right i think it's i think
you know who could wear this
ginny jennifer goodwin could really pull
this off this would be a fun
nashville wedding dress with like you
know with boots
okay this is a long white sleek dress
with ombre pink on the bottom creeping
up to the mid-calf a little
little surprise of color oh you thought
my dress was white no no no no there's a
little problem no
i'm a techno tampon yeah it's a little
playtex cheek
it looks a little tampony it looks like
someone got bored dying an easter egg
and i was like well
good enough just gave up halfway through
okay this one
okay i like this for a couple reasons
it's got an ice blue tulle bottom
and a very simple white top
i like it business on the top party on
the bottom business on the top
frozen on the bottom it's frozen on the
top
yeah it is a little else frozen yeah it
is a little too disney princess it just
reminds me of like the way they used to
dress like jessica simpson and then back
in the day
oh my god that is so like music video
cover like the cover of their album
this is this is this is carrie underwood
she's about to break into that oh god
it's so true
okay you were in that this one is a
flesh
i'm really into flesh color wedding
dresses i don't know why i am so
desperate to look um like i have scurvy
on my wedding day
uh but i think it really
would bring out the veins in my neck so
it's like a band-aid
like an ethereal band-aid she looks like
she
she's like she came off a fairy's knee
and glided into the wedding
see my mind goes to like a gorgeous
paper bag to cover up your alcohol
yeah i mean it's it's a gorgeous dress i
mean i will have my flashlight between
my tits
wedding to me this was like a costume i
like you know what i love i love that
the top and the bottom are like
different it's like a franken dress it's
like they don't belong together and i
kind of like the chaos of it
i mean they're like oh whitney lost her
mind she got married and bought this
fucking dress
um okay this forget the neck part
because this has a big it has a
yeah neck it has a separate dress which
is the most interesting part of the
dress
i know but i'd be too tempted to hang
myself so i think you can see the
nipples through this one you can hang
yourself in that big red cord
yes i mean you know that red cord it's
kind of like you might find your second
husband at your first wedding wait you
know
in horror movies or stories when like
they have the ribbon around their neck
and like if you untie it the head falls
off
i kind of feel like that's what's going
on with this belt like if you were to
take off that ribbon like your torso
or the tube that feeds babies in the
womb vary that
i l i just like this color it's like a
new like a
um fleshy like a beigey flesh
well it's like dirty dishwater okay all
right that's a pass
this is is is the same color but a
pop of purple tool underneath what
we're fun we're a fun couple we might be
swingers we might cheat on each other
but we have fun we drink whiskey during
the day
i like this because it looks like she's
made of smoke and if i was in a wedding
i would also want to disappear
[Laughter]
but the top is very like skims it is
like a skims yeah
kim kardashian might sue me but yeah
it's not a good sign if my the dress
choice i like looks like it also sports
bra it also looks like all your guests
spilled wine and you just walk through
it
i like it yeah and it does kind of look
like you mopped something up
with your yeah you're like i'll get it
that red wine i'm gonna get it
just shimmy on over there i'm a swiffer
taylor swiffer i do i don't
white i would be worried the entire time
that it was going to get like salsa on
it or like
some shit on it why are you having salsa
at all your weddings i guess salsa is
delicious and i will also have
shakshouka in my wedding i will have red
wine i will have
come in here i will have ketchup there
will be a hot dog truck there's going to
be a lot of water
a tomato-based wedding yes there should
be a lot there's sponsored by campbell's
yes
there will be pizza trucks i just tasted
those pizza rolls barbecue sauce red
sauces are a big part of my life
and they will be at my okay can someone
write that down as a quote
red sauces they are think about it pizza
ketchup barbecue sauce salsa four of my
favorite things
blood up there if you don't have covet
okay this is you're gonna hate this i
know you're gonna hate this
this is a column dress that gets super
mermaidy at the bottom the mermaid gown
but i like it because you can't you'll
you shimmy you shimmy down there looks
like she's standing on a pile of water
have you ever seen a girl have you ever
seen a girl fall
i've seen many times i've seen a bride
fall uh trip over her dress
i've tripped a bride it's brutal you
ever done makeup for weddings
it's brutal watching i feel like i would
never fall in this because you have to
walk off
and just that orchestra of everyone like
oh oh it's the first all
of them it's the worst it's the worst
it's a nightmare loading through the
venue
yeah would it be great if you fall and
then you just keep rolling like stroll
and roll
and roll within the aisle burrito i
would just get up and leave i'd be like
all right we're done here
like we'll try again i'm planning
another one i would grab the back of the
carpet roll it up with me
like in room yeah but the time i got to
the front to tilt me up and like hello
i'm trying to sneak the kid out of the
room no i would fall and i'd be like
dude get it you better
kept rolling this is gorgeous this is a
black
wedding dress with a opening in the
vagina
this is a pussy dress this is the
blackest pubes and then it just goes
into a
full-blown opening i don't have a piece
it looks like mold
this is like mold okay and i really like
that but this is for someone else
this is for like ruby rose this is for
kat von d this is
cool i'm saying you're not this cool
they're this kind of cool
you're a different kind of next this
benton knows about this dress i have
been
showing it to people for the past four
years because this was my number one
pick
when i was engaged it is victor and rolf
gown that i love
mocking femininity or like cartoon
femininity
and this has like six like cartoon bows
on the back different types of bows i
love it
yeah i love it i love it and if you
can't make your mind i like i don't know
which bow i wanted it's kind of like a
spine
made out of it looks like a straight
jacket it
looks like this looks like what this
looks like is they said all right guys
we have to finish
we have to finish our wedding collection
what should we do with that we have
these bows
dressed our straight jacket i love it
it's bellevue i used to have some joke
that was like um
uh you're i mean there's a reason they
call it an institution
oh yeah they had some jokes something
about that so have it wear a straight
jacket your wedding let everyone know it
just looks like they didn't try that
hard just like
they were like they're running out of
time they hot glued these bows in the
back of this dress
but again it's hot glued i'll get it if
the bows are like a different texture if
they're if they're like faux leather if
they're
if they're velvet there's something else
i could dazzle them
okay i am oh i have my whole life
thought that i was going to
wear pants to my wedding ever since i
saw celine dion in that backwards white
suit
at the grammys whatever that was 15
years ago i was like that's what i'm
doing at my wedding i just want to make
sure i emasculate
my groom day one i liked what she wore i
like this too but i want a jacket over
it because this just feels like oh
this is a good pant like a onesie
pantsuit
yeah this is the lamp she's a lamp she
has a lamp shadow she gets this
shit she's in disguise she forgets
that she was ready she rubbed up
someone's skirt this looks like they're
looking for her and she's in the bridal
room like i'm a little bit shy
you can't find me oh no
they're like where could she be where is
stacy she is ready for covet is what
she's ready for she's just holding a
light bulb in her mouth like
uh okay this pantsuit i have had in my
save folder for a very long time benton
please describe it to us
um this would what this is what you
would wear if you were going for
halloween as madonna
it's a white pants you sold me on gold
chains
it's very um britney spears madonna
music video it's very like
i own 13 of this company because the
rest i spent on this suit
it does look really expensive for no
reason
it has hot glue chains on it of two
different colors
i mean why is that of you it's just
stupid okay
all right this is really upsetting you
let's move on yeah benton's triggered
you guys i'm not sure why but
okay this is cool it is a lace is
a this is kind of western to me i like
it
that's what i like about it it's like
boots uh bell bottoms and the way that
they make this
uh the hips go out it you know kind of
cartoons i would want an actual boot
and i would want more of a bell bottom
that would really that would be it to me
because the top to me should be smaller
and the pant should be bigger
dude this is like like fucking bitch
this is like almost famous vibe
my prenup is not a joke i mean if you
are go walking down the island this your
dude is like
this is i have a wedding but i have to
get back to the ranch in 30.
we're birthing a calf soon that's
exactly what it is
that's my shit dude and i love like just
like a messy bun with it
like this whole look is like this
wedding better fucking move this better
i've got shit to do this is gonna be an
efficient ass wedding i'm obsessed
sorry guys i'm eating oh are we done
that's it that's it
that was it oh okay so did we pick a
wedding dress for me for
my fake wedding in my head i would pick
trying again okay is there a do-over
with i mean i will i will have multiple
weddings yes i i feel like we can give
you i do think that you should wear
pants i think that's very cool i think
you should wear pants i like i like a
flesh tone
i like that western theme i think you
should take these ideas and then have
someone design you something something
you think you should just have multiple
costume changes i wouldn't
costumes did you hear that wigs yeah i
think you should have different looks
why limit yourself i will wear full like
halloween costumes i think you should
wear a two-piece horse suit
i'll do that well with someone else
standing behind me in the back i'll be
the only
ass and then we'll write and then you
can write you have an incredible ass
do i you have jamie we talk about it all
the time
are you serious your ass is phenomenal
wait that's the best news i've ever
heard
are you kidding stand up you don't have
instagram we'll both stand up okay but
okay stand up look at her but look at
look at her butt am i allowed to do this
yes i am
wow how great her brother not according
to time magazine yes you are why not
look at her butt
wait okay look it's fucking wild what
stand on your tippy toes yes but hold on
yes look how incredible your ass is
wild dude oh see i wish that butts
had been popular during my formative
years because i've just spent my entire
life being like
please get rid of it oh you're but i
would
pay good money for that question many
people are paying good money for i've
i've got boobs like an idiot and boobs
are no longer guys don't like that shit
anymore
it's all about butts well this that
really just made my day
good it's like uh we talk about it all
the time
yes oh my god we sexually harass you
constantly
objectify you like that is the sweetest
thing anyone said oh and you know we did
we haven't talked about are we friends
we have not even opened the podcast we
haven't even
oh we knew the answer no we don't people
don't know we're friends
i'm not even sure if we're friends um i
feel like
during covid we became more friends but
i like
really want to like legit be your friend
because i think you're so delightful
i love you but but what what i didn't
really know you i know
we like we ran into each other i was in
new york and then we ran into each other
in general i for my whole kind of life
have been kind of scared of new york
comics
i feel like they look down on la this
was a projection
oh sure we feel like like we're corny
we're uh you know like
our venues aren't as whatever i feel
like new york comics are kind of like i
was just
intimidated by them oh you feel like a
new york comic to me you feel like a new
york comic who just like
was smart and like came to la early and
found success while the rest of us were
just like hitting up open mics
thank you so there's that yeah also
you're friends with phoebe robinson
she's like one of my oldest dearest
that's kind of how and i feel like we
connected that fucking elf thing yeah we
met the elephant we met that's right
women and women it was me comedy issue
you tiffany
krista alonso kate mckinnon kate
mckinnon
it was for her l cover yeah it was such
a good time
yes and we met and i i like didn't
really know what to do with
you there no oh okay okay i was like
wait why did i not meet you
uh and then uh we kind of uh
like i don't know like we didn't get a
time to bond and i have this thing where
if i meet a failed male comic and we
don't get so close right away i'm like i
guess we're just nothing oh
like i was just like why did you eat
that no it's just my thing i remember
after that
i feel like you should be best friends
instantly it's so unhealthy oh no
see i yeah i have that too though a
little bit yeah like so we're not gonna
be besties but i remember
the few minutes that we did get to talk
about things we were pulled in a million
directions and then there was that like
dinner afterwards with that really long
ass tape very weird and i know we didn't
get to sit near each other and yeah i
just i remember being like oh i hope we
like get to hang more
and it was in that very quick moment i
was like
ooh yeah this feels like a person i
would yeah like we should be friends
and then yeah and then uh during covid
we kind of like
got to know i got to like know you yeah
because you are like there you are
like successful and beautiful and and i
there it is a little thing
where it's like are we gonna be friends
are we gonna fight each other do we have
to kill each other like there is that
comes up it's real it's fucking real
it's like primordial
i think not just in our job i think i
used when i first started stand up i had
that so
badly like there were comedians where i
was like they're like gorgeous and
hilarious like
i cannot compete there's only one woman
in our lineup much less
we're the same like we're the same box
to check i don't think that well it's me
or you
i know but it's just like it's like a
primordial thing that's like oh i guess
it's me or her but then
isn't it so nice to kind of like grow up
and grow out of that thinking more
like you start to just be like who
fucking cares yes who gives a shit gives
a shit
let's all just like hang out and also
that's just so um uh
such an obsolete way of thinking because
now it's just like there's so
you can get success without just going
on stage and
you know yeah stage time like there's
other ways right you can't yeah
you kind of can't like cheat the system
like or you actually can shoot the
system you can do
you can have so many avenues so why and
when one person does well it actually
helps everyone you know absolutely
but you also i didn't meet you when i
did crashing yeah that's right because i
wasn't in new york
that summer they were filming that was
the first season of crashing yeah okay
yes because you were actually maybe no
sorry that was the second season of
crashing but i wasn't in that episode so
i wasn't
i just wasn't around when you were
filming right right yeah yeah
yeah so i didn't get to meet you for
that yeah look at us you were great in
that show
that was a great i love that really i
never saw it oh i love it
it's so funny because henry's a browser
he's in it i also love an episode
yeah it's a great episode it's one of my
favorite ones i
yeah i don't really i remember because
you guys shot on film
yeah i was very stressed out by that
sure
wait why are you choking yourself why
are you dropping yourself
coming um i'm talking about a tv
appearance on
this has been very fun you're very fun
thank you
and you're very lovely thank you and we
love to end these on a really sweet note
i'm a sweet boy we like to have a sweet
note ending here and we just want to
know who you would like to physically
find and then publicly cancel
um i'm gonna
we'll we'll bleep it okay oh wait oh
what's up
you oh it could be anyone yeah i've
never heard benton asked this question
yeah i'm trying
i'm this is all fake do you have an
answer
i don't have one i just want to make
that uncomfortable i thought it'd be a
fun clip
oh my god i thought you'd be a fun clip
where you answered we just bleep it like
no one really knows
so funny what oh stop leaving my emails
oh my god i wasn't like what do you mean
oh no no i literally was staring at the
corner of that screen oh god
um okay better question yeah do you
think whitney can make it to her show in
20 minutes i mean if she's up first
you know i'm not that stresses me out
for you you guys finish the podcast
well i want to talk more to jamie but
we're just enough to make you she's been
here all day i know we've shot a bunch
of stuff with you she may be hungry
i know i know i know she's literally
just
i'm like no we're going to sit down and
just talk we're going to reminisce we're
going to go down memory lane i'm
two hours late for a show and a wedding
dress okay and you probably have to go
too
um i love you we do have these awkwardly
don't ride elephants um
the uh wedding coach on netflix now
watch it watch it watch it crashing yeah
on hbo
max not in my ambassador but whatever no
i'm not in your episode but i am on the
show
and i do love that show see it's one of
the other i what did i tell you what
they're like whitney's on the top so
jamie can't be here see i told you oh my
god
actually whenever someone whenever this
air we're just gonna put her on one
episode and you'll be on a different one
um and then um and jamie lee socials oh
yeah
literally jamie lee on instagram yeah
i'm considering deleting twitter so okay
i don't know where i'm at with that
right now but yeah you can find me on
instagram not really jamie lee
nice i love you okay thank you for doing
this thank you
don't worry elephants okay don't worry
elephants
the dewey trail mix
four four four four